hey bootleg kev here listen in denver
for the weekend you know we had to pull
up and uh and tap in with the city this
is the most impromptu cipher that's
about to kick off shout out my god dj k
tone
shout out to everybody hey just so get
the hotel room we just set up shop in
the [ __ ] hotel room we got the
bed you know what i'm saying everybody
real quick before we uh we we set it off
man just shout yourself out shout out
your [ __ ] promote your [ __ ] we gonna get
right to it i go by they call him ap
represent wins and losses squizzy shout
out dj katong like i said appreciate
boulette kev having us [ __ ] with us
some of the hardest in the city well the
hardest in the city [ __ ] ain't no
question trev rich man this is crazy the
best part about it is i got to do this
with my dogs you know what i'm saying so
we turned up squeezy gang y'all know
what i'm revving let's go what's
happening y'all man this amazing man
that's a space nba zy you know what i'm
saying protect your energy out right now
cop that for me you know what i'm saying
shout out to the team barbershop on cut
we gonna keep it moving dj k tone you
know i had to call the best in the city
i get the call i called in big shout out
to john blaze boulet kev i appreciate
y'all you know me dj k town that dj k
town denver colorado yes sir the box day
baby himself 1-0-0
p-a-c-k-s-a-v-y honey pack savvy man
shout out katong shout out boulette kev
we ain't here thuggin with my dogs man
real box day babies in his [ __ ]
hey if i keep rapping i'm just thinking
how it's about to be i bossed up on
every single person that was doubting me
learn my lesson [ __ ] with broke hoes
they be annoying me so if my next [ __ ]
bring her acne she could join the team
straight like that no faking my rap this
not a game been [ __ ] with your ass
for seven years but you just not the
same i ain't gonna lie i guess you could
say that i'm the blame i caught up in my
foolish ways when the [ __ ] am i gonna
change i ain't gonna say never but i
guess it's for the better heart cold
chrome hard sweater for the different
weather back though by my own mans like
we don't know each other [ __ ] it i got a
x amount you are not my brother [ __ ]
used to sleep on my flow let them use my
covers she had me [ __ ] up you try to
play me like a sucker i'm hitting [ __ ]
baby mamas i'm a [ __ ] so if a
[ __ ] hit my baby mama so what [ __ ] it
to the game you gotta charge it i
haven't seen and been through a lot like
i'm parking best believe imma finish it
if you started put that red dot on your
dog's eye this ain't target where the
love go where the loyalty this [ __ ] fell
[ __ ] it i can't even trust my damn self
really ran it up on my own don't need no
damn help this chop hotter than a [ __ ]
and make a fan mail shout out to
everybody [ __ ] with me shout out to
them hating ass dicks sucking [ __ ]
plotting on me sneak dissing on the net
but see me wanna dap about me my little
brother got me fresh in this dapper
money i always keep it a hunch oh you
keep a half of 50. to be honest name a
[ __ ] out here rapping with me
don't worry i'll wait my [ __ ] like to
slide like canine on them skates when
this [ __ ] bark a canine in your face
while i'm eating a banana drop a dime on
your place i love life i love being me i
swear to god these [ __ ] ass [ __ ] they
ain't seeing me
[ __ ] i got the rock just like pnb baby
girl just said i'm disrespectful it's
depending me since seventh grade been
throwing that [ __ ] up it's the gm i
swear to god these [ __ ] ass [ __ ] they
ain't seeing me [ __ ]
these hoe be so cap you get a real one
gotta have a back she add to you you
can't subtract from her where you learn
you're mad pay some people to walk about
my life i don't want them back i spend
that cash you spend your time impressing
people you swear you hate we can't
relate my word is born if yours is fake
we can't debate bet the money lying on
us every time cause we came to play no
blueprint [ __ ] right away [ __ ] eat
all paper plates steal this [ __ ] all day
today my a to b bang the bank first name
basis with the move of shakers need my
40 acres run to play triangle offense
hit la miami vegas nothing bout me
minimal i couldn't accept them wages she
been passed around and i can't wife no
little hot potato freaky [ __ ] got a
body fixed [ __ ] deep and [ __ ] head
weight not a bad weight she gonna sleep
in it stopping [ __ ] the ones who hate
the most no they ain't dropping [ __ ]
keep this [ __ ] a brick name the [ __ ]
cause it's obvious i made it about that
dirt never care about being first people
i love have switched up on me ain't
gonna act like it ain't hurt pray i see
my [ __ ] everywhere except upon this
shirt if you owe me i won't [ __ ] your
[ __ ] i'll curve it cause that's worse
off divert off the vert my [ __ ] jumping
over sleep when y'all hoes do the walk
of shame with a smile no you eat i ain't
got no couples goals couple hoes but
that's it
[Music]
how you mad i'm up you not [ __ ] we got
the same clock know some [ __ ] in the
league and we got the same box built my
name up so much now even my haters name
dropped we ain't homies [ __ ] just
because we got the same ops doing
business with some [ __ ] who got rich
off in them trenches they see murder
everyday but not him credit lines no
limit gotta be careful who i [ __ ] with
because i love you to go missing heard
you only gonna love five and i don't
walk that on [ __ ] [ __ ] come on
while you win this race you ain't going
the distance my young [ __ ] love to
shoot and he shows persistence
reputation speaking need no intros or
resistance been the walking reason in
these streets you could go in the
instance murder motives over letting
their motorcycle marcus guns won't
caucus no safety for foes or imposters
show stoppers cold cases and no for the
coppers when they show to ask for
information we ghosts with the mobsters
yell and catch me if you can just some
g's in the wind big [ __ ] vibes i wanna
feel like a breeze in the bench [ __ ]
just let me count this bread till i
leave with some friends suck me like i
need i say we even for squeezing you in
a lot of [ __ ] really woofing they said
it i'm walking ironically they've been
the broken [ __ ] that is a coffee come
reviving no beef you ain't felt it too
often i'ma get you real familiar with it
though i'm going if my [ __ ] go big bad
tony rank you macaroni this 40 on your
40 if i had it on me when debo hit your
block you [ __ ] tucked your chains that
bike screech i'm like he's ill the way i
blast your homie somebody's over here
taking a [ __ ] ain't gotta tell nobody
else they know the ticket i spent we
loud likes the friday smokey house got
hit you play with money then you playing
with emotions need to double your
devotion i do not trust no words just
actions holding down shift when y'all
rap big captain [ __ ] y'all been saying
made up pig latin bout your whole style
from louisiana fashion see i've been the
truth since the east denver
m-c-a-m-e-a-z-y
that is what you call a real [ __ ] that
can rhyme threw three fingers up told
them read between the lines gave no
[ __ ] like a nun headed out like a lung
running [ __ ] four by one i'm the anchor
connie chung uh now i'm lit like you
spike the [ __ ] punch they say take a
leap of faith so i did it from the jump
see i started from the bottom till i
made me some now my name ring bells me
and le'veon i built mine off of hard
work and dedication now let's talk about
your fabricating you can't claim you
sold out cause you opened up a show then
people bought tickets for that main act
they say numbers don't lie but that's
actually a lie if you pay enough money
you can change stats while your streams
don't equate to a fan base wait they
coming later well i can't stay you
[ __ ] fake it till you make it but what
happens when you don't then you just a
fake [ __ ] that's a damn shame see i'll
never fall for the okie just being
honest i've been around the block before
ben wallace mindset was [ __ ] the
attention do it regardless whole bunch
of sideline [ __ ] sweat at they targets
9 [ __ ] staying yo lane like roy munson
just made a lot of cash i really enjoyed
touching made a new vibe and she
strictly just in the [ __ ] [ __ ] had
me so hard off her head gave me
concussions
damn that's not an exaggeration it's
evident i'm dope this verse is an
affidavit probably be further if [ __ ]
hadn't awaited but i'm getting paid to
do what i love [ __ ] i made it it's
amazing hey i know you just watched a
brand new freestyle presented to you by
our good folks at lrg don't forget if
you go to lrg right now the website will
be right there broom l dash r dash g.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
get 30 percent off your order that's l r
dash g.com you'll see it right down
there
save 30 off your order by putting in
that promo code bootleg and shout out to
lrg we got another freestyle coming next
week